hello everybody and welcome to let's
play these slender mod yeah this is um
actually something that I overlooked for
a long time I mean people told me about
it but I assumed it was the same thing
but I was convinced recently that
slender mod is very different based upon
the original Slender game by parsec okay
so I'm not exactly sure what to expect I
assume it's you know same general
formula as the other ones but whoa
oh I'm slow okay anyway so I see
something flashing in the distance there
might be one ha Jay not sure though
ooh that music is much creeper I once
again I've started really cranking up
the volume in my headset so oh hello I
see two little flashy thingies Oh is
there a path I'm supposed to follow I
don't know I like the black and white
film grain what's this then oh hello
that looks like a page I get up there
yes it is loud
alright yeah
this isn't what I was expecting I mean
forest yes but what the hell whoa whoa
whoa what is that what the hell is that
uh-huh uh-huh alright I kind of expected
it to not be this intense when it
started see the tall man sounds about
right
oh that's familiar
oh wow this is positively diabolical
okay I thought I saw another glowy bit
eyes at it no yes I don't know
can't even tell I have no idea what the
layout of the map is here so I'm just
wandering if there's a path you can yell
at me later because right now I'm I
doesn't look good whatever I'm walking
towards
okay yeah that's not good that's not
good at all why am I going towards that
why why because I'm a fool to myself and
I live to entertain people with screams
of Terror ah my best friend yeah sure I
don't think it works that way little
girl
I'm assumed that's the only one in here
okay no sign is Slendy yet okay
good god what's that it's at a rock rock
from the flat got some tree thoughts
Lindy's hand what ah no skip skip skip
skip skip skip way flap flip flap flap
okay yeah and it's loud
okay enough up there you go all right
the breathing supposed to taper off
after a while
but either way oh man this is freaky
what is that what's going on there this
is a graphical error probably mean not
like II mean not like II yeah I just
probably graph glare ah no oh get away
get away you do oh I'm gonna listen to
this again oh yeah I'm so tired fat you
can't walk three feet okay lady god no
wonder the Slenderman gets you you're
probably 600 pounds five foot one 600
pounds trying to run your way through a
forest what you've been doing out here
golly oh what's that
I've kind of been walking in one
direction I don't know how big this
forest is it seems pretty huge if you
know what I mean okay I don't know I'm
just trying to I'm probably gonna die I
know that I'm just saying that right now
it's it's me come on everybody it's me
playing this game I'm probably gonna die
so ha what is that so I'm just trying to
get a lay of the land before I do
it's a pile of rocks but this particular
pile of rocks has a page in it slightly
always watches okey-dokey sounds good
dude
hi buddy hi there how you doing
you're not making my screen fuzzy oh
wait that's not Slenderman oh yeah it is
okay nevermind I think I see something
over there
musics getting a little too intense for
my taste I was like looking right at him
I thought it was originally like some
statue that was supposed to look like
him that was supposed to throw people
off because it wasn't McMahon that is
getting loud it's not a lot for you guys
as it is for me right now
okay here the train tracks that I
spawned on oh look it's a tunnel thingy
look is that's a page over there I am
thoroughly freaked out and I can't even
hear myself talk but that's okay but I
will persevere I like this game I like
it it's not good don't run don't run ha
running screw your stupid advice I'm
running Kali man I tell you what out of
all the Slender games the music in this
one is freaking me out more than
anything like my god
what the heck is this what is this I
don't even know ah here I got right leg
run please thank you Oh getting some
shape why don't you I see something over
there
he's right behind me isn't he he's right
behind me I know his hit right behind me
I'm pretty sure about that one
yep no is that a page how did I miss a
page on that thing I looked around it
fuddy run that's what I was doing man I
mean come on
runnings you only wow it's getting
louder I can't hear a damn thing now you
probably could hear this through my
headset right now whoa now sort of
rumbling has started I don't see Sundy
anywhere Oh what is that I thought I saw
some white are we cooling off
are we cooling off guys guys is that
just me sign these clothes what is that
is that a wolf what is that
how big is this freaking place behind
you
no don't say that he's not you're a liar
you're dirty like all my guys placing
freaking huge oh it's so big okay I
don't know where he went
you only had six pages and the other
ones he's like right behind you
holding down I'm so mon boned I am I am
boned this is the worst this is bad
numero uno primero VAT Oh I got six of
eight pages oh that's not bad for my
first try but oh oh I got the shivers I
got goose bumps
I don't wanna see where did he go I kind
of concern now cuz normally in the other
sunder games it was predictable because
he was always behind you and now I don't
see him so I don't know oh man I've got
six of eight pages but I I have no set
pattern that I've gone I let see white
I'm gonna turn to white get away no oh
crap oh crap
Oh in terms of atmosphere this might be
one of the worst slender Maps I've ever
played just the music in the location
it's like counterintuitive to what I
remember because the music kind of got
quieter and stranger huh what's this
some place where a page might be
I like it I do not like this it's weird
it's like no matter what direction I
turn I kind of go to new places
r.i.p Felix Arvid Ulf Kjellberg ha I
knew it
he follows ok seven of eight holy hell I
don't know where to go though mmm wait I
saw a flicker of white I see white hey I
see something in the distance all please
may ho God I said I said oh my god
that's the last page I'm not gonna make
it I'm not gonna make it I see something
I saw oh please don't be just that house
oh please don't be that I could have
sworn AHA I see I thought I heard like
breathing behind me okay that's too
quiet oh it's too quiet do quiet I
thought I saw like just a flicker just
the smallest itty-bitty flicker oh no oh
no oh no
I swear whatever I'm breathing or my
character ping I hear this like
breathing behind me why is everything so
quiet Oh
huh oh no it was a door no that's that
yeah I got my gummy gummy gummy gummy
gummy enemy what now what now
got that let me alone I got your pages
what do i do what do I do
he's right by mister day he's right
behind me what do I do
I got all your pages I don't know how
but I did what do i do what do i do what
do i do what do i do I run that's what I
do
ok I'm back at the rocks what does it
mean doesn't help me at all
Oh victory there you're a dick
you're an a-hole oh no you're great oh
oh I think I won question mark
congratulations for finding all eight
notes yes a one no I never have to play
it again
aah Oh God all right so ha man love bad
really bad that's creepy as hell man
that music I think turning the music up
in my headphones or the sound of really
affects me a bit more so I'm gonna keep
doing it for all the games now oh okay
I turned around cuz was wondering where
he was that I turned around and he was
there in case you didn't get well it was
a bee I turn around he was there so I
turned around again and he was still
there good
I turned he's not there turn there Oh
turn ha
and then I died anyway that was fun ooh
terrible book fun anyway so I'm on time
thank you guys so much for watching
click the annotations for more videos
that I've done and as always I'll see
you in the next part video thing but I